just knowing that videos online and
anyone can watch at any time it makes me
feel sick I had met this guy online and
on a band's page his name was Chris I
was 16 at the time and he was 19 we
started chatting because obviously like
we were into the same music we started
off just sending pictures to each other
just sort of like smiley faces or just
like but he started asking the sexual
pictures of me I really didn't want to
send them like I hadn't done anything
like that before and it felt really
weird he just kept saying to me like it
wasn't a big deal and everyone was doing
it and he would stop talking to me if I
did in I just kind of yeah I did it in
the end
[Music]
he wanted to meet up with me so we went
out and then he took me to his place we
we had sex that night actually the next
time his tone changed
he was like quite scary and controlling
he started then saying he wanted to film
us having sex yeah I let him film us
one of my best friends came to me and he
said that he had seen a video of me in
case having sex online that was the
worst Chris uploaded it to a porn
website I think it was also difficult I
just can't even make it in college
I felt so embarrassed ashamed and so
alone because I didn't know who else had
ever been through something like that
the police got involved after my parents
found out it was horrible because I
didn't want anything to do that anymore
I wanted it to be over but they wanted
to press charges because what Chris had
done was illegal because I was under 18
at the time he filmed me and uploaded it
they said that everyone else that would
have seen the video online had broken
the law as well chris is now on the sex
offenders register I feel really angry
about what he did to me I trusted him
and I feel really angry towards the
other guys as well because they may as
well have been in the room at the time
it's taking me a lot of counseling to
try and get every what's happened
no matter why I do that video always
going to be online
and I just hate I can't get it back
[Applause]